im jahr 2050 wird das internet
tausendfach schneller sein als heute
ingenieure aus aller welt arbeiten an
umweltfreundlichen lösungen um auch die
entlegensten winkel der erde zu
vernetzen
es geht nicht nur darum jedem menschen
zugang zum internet zu ermöglichen
sondern ihn auch mit moralisch
vertretbaren technologien zu versorgen
die digitalen technologien werden uns
körperlich und geistig und zwei orten
gleichzeitig sein
wir brauchen unsere fingerspitzen und
schon eröffnet sich eine virtuelle
digitale welt unser ziel ist eine
perfekte illusion der realen welt zu
kreieren
[Musik]
mondrian
im schlimmsten fall aus meiner
perspektive gesehen werden wir ständig
kommunizieren
das würde bedeuten dass wir in online
[Applaus]